[Music]
welcome to the data science hangout
everyone the first one since posit com
uh for all those that I met it was great
meeting you this is your first data
science hangout welcome if this is your
100th or more welcome we're happy to
have you I'm filling in for Rachel today
she's ordinarily the the host um she's
taking a well-deserved vacation um so
I'll do my best this is a casual open
environment for data scientists data
science leaders interns students what
have you um so we wanted to be a free
flowing conversation super welcoming so
you know use your best judgment be nice
um there's lots of different ways to
participate you can um chat in Hannah
will share a slido link where you can
ask anonymous questions uh you can raise
your hand you can turn your video on you
can um just sort of speak so it's super
casual whatever works for you um I'm
really happy to introduce our leader
today Jean vinant uh from Nestle um so
I'll hand it over to him to do it to uh
to an intro and we'll get started okay
great thank you very much um for the the
nice intro and yeah just to to build on
what you've just said um so I've been
assisting to uh I would say some of this
uh this uh
uh Hangouts uh honestly it's also
sometimes collapsing but it's in the end
of the day here because I'm in Europe so
that's why sometimes a bit difficult to
attend but I just want to reiterate that
it's really um well it's a pleasure for
us to be here and to an honor to have
been asked to share my my experience
with you uh and um and just I'm sharing
then this experience as a person so uh
just to make sure that everyone is is
also align on this I'm not here
representing
as a n employee I would say but I'm
happy to share with with my experience
throughout my different companies also
and and more recently n of course um so
speaking of which I actually medicated
as a physicist so I did a physics in the
Swiss Federal Institute of Technology in
loan uh and then after that I did a PhD
in in Neuroscience so where I have I was
exploring the connection uh between
neurons doing so more biophysics and
that would be through
electrophysiology that's where I started
to do some data analytics more rather
heavily involved in in both analyzing
the signal to get uh some relevant
features out of that and then doing
statistics to to get the what would be
uh the what would be the uh the message
or learnings to get from that basically
I was exploring how neurons were were
connecting and disconnecting over
12-hour period uh with with actual
slices of of tissue then after that I
moved to the industry and I started uh
to work as a process engineer in vtronic
technology which is a company in
Switzerland uh with also a production
site in in Solon in the US um so in in
Ohio and um I work there so as a process
engineering micro Electronics uh to do
assembly for medical devices so we were
working on outside medical device but
also some uh some implants and that was
it was a bit more challenging because
and that's where we have this um uh this
Neuroscience also that was interesting
for for the company uh with the neuros
stimulators so I've been there uh
successively um process engineer then
head of engineering uh and development
and then the head of Technology uh
taking care of the the the portfolio of
Technology an interaction with customers
so Tech vonic is a service company so we
don't have we didn't have any direct
product but we would develop an
industrialize products for
customers uh and then uh after seven
years in that company I moved to nesle
as a data
scientist uh and then I uh there I
worked in different projects uh in the
system Technology Centers so uh it's
located in or Switzerland
um where this um this is Center where we
develop all the well so-call system so
system is the the the conjunction of the
machine dispensing machine the packaging
which is functional to some extent more
or less but sometimes more than less and
the product uh and one of the most known
is Nespresso I would say the Nespresso
system with the the virtual L that you
have in the in the US or uh we also have
DOL Gusto and different things like this
that are um uh around that so I work
there really in different project as
data scientist with design of
experiments with statistical process
control with also some automating uh
data analysis that were coming from the
labs where the lab would generate a lot
of different files and we would need to
have some uh apps that would then uh uh
and that would be shiny apps then that
would
be using and analyzing the data to to
extract the the knowledge of it and then
drive the drive the development and uh
recently so this summer I moved to nle
research so moving a bit away from the
production I would say closer to uh to
more Upstream uh process in research and
development and now I'm still working in
in in in programming and having these um
on
um uh more applied in the food science
and so it's a broader than just the
system stre touching all the N
categories
there um as side or say part of my
activity also in that could be
interesting and that's why I'm sharing
it also with you because there might be
some questions uh also around that uh
I've very early in nesle joined uh the
network so we have knowledge networks in
nesle uh in R&D where we actually see
connect uh different people from
different sites just to give you an idea
um I don't know exactly how many sites
but I think we have sites all over the
the globe um and then sometimes the T
scientists are there one of their kind
or maybe two of them and it's good to
connect so that we can share on
experience we can share on on tricks we
can share on knowledge and uh and also
get some some coaching and and and
mentoring also each other um so this
data in network I've joined when I join
almost at the same time and more
recently I've been in the well for for
sometime already in the leadership team
and for the past two years I've been
leading that network uh so really
coordinating the the different
activities for the this network in the
uh in N so
um so that's a bit about my history in
in in a short term I don't know I
haven't looked at the uh uh at the
questions I don't if you could spot some
of the questions already if there is any
question on this question questions
typically come in you know maybe
starting now so if you have any
questions you know please uh type into
the chat or uh you can use the slide or
you can just uh hop on with video and
audio I see Mike actually has a question
Mike nice to see you yeah hi there hi
joh um so what is the size of the data
science group at Nestle and I'm sorry if
I missed
this uh well I didn't mention so that's
a good question um I would say that uh
it depends how you how you define data
sense um typically the networks I would
start from my close Community or my
closer to me uh the the network I'm in
we are typically around 50 uh that would
be for R&D um 50 60 but not everyone
would s of completely exhaustive and
they more recently did uh data science
so and these people I would say would be
more really in the in the development
and now
kind of hard coders I would say Al
people either using r or or python or
both um but then when you extend also to
a lot of analysts that could then be
also using so more less coding or no
code Solutions It Gos bigger and when
you look at also Beyond R&D I would say
a number that came recently up is
something like around a thousand uh a
thousand knowing that nesle is 300,000
people around the world uh including all
the factories of course and then you can
have a very
diverse approaches because we have
people in the in the business who would
be more looking at um you know
dashboards I would say it's really
around data Vis visualization which is
already uh teaching a lot I mean
basically having a just showing what is
there I mean how many times I've got
people coming to me with a Nexel sheet
and say oh we see this and this and this
on the numbers and say um yeah well try
plotting your data and that's one of the
thing we say also in the in the the
course we give is is really plot the
data that's the first thing to do so
this is already very valuable and here
typically using forbi type of solutions
so we have many people in the business
doing this there is also a lot of of
activity in the supply chain uh that
I've heard of for all the demand
planning and these kind of things so
there there's been things like this and
and in various fields of of n so that's
why when you extend it Beyond R&D it
goes It goes there but it might be
in also approaches and and techniques
that I'm less familiar with as I'm much
more into I would
say technically generated data
or yeah machine or instruments generate
data yeah if I may can I have a
follow-up question then Rob so um when
you were talking about the communities
to try to bring together um you know
data scientists or practitioners then so
is that primarily your 50 or is that
actually reaching out
broader no it's primarily the 50 I would
say because it's it's really much more
around doing the same activity um well
we've seen here in the in the Hangouts
so we have some commonalities across
what the different activities of the
scientist but we also have might be
quite different and I think that when
you are treating um some some I don't
know data for supply chain or or human
resource data uh or data coming from
Mass spectrometer is not exactly the
same so you have somehow the same
techniques behind but also where we are
more than just machine or calculating
machines is because so we are having
some knowledge about the domain uh and
and typically uh when I was you know you
know I know now I think a lot about
coffee also because I worked for coffee
projects and when I I was there you know
really seeing the connecting the dot for
sometimes because you're like people
they come with a request and they have a
certain perspective from their project
and then also as a data scientist you
can say well look I I understand what
you what you would like to do and I can
understand because I also know what is
the context and what is the science
behind to some extent I'm not pretending
I'm at the level but to some extent we
know this this and then we can we can
help so that's why this community I
would say more in our Ry which is
already pretty a challenge to manage um
because we see that we have different uh
different
um uh also approaches uh you have to
know that in in n r we have so food
science the most obvious or systems then
the product Technology Centers who
develop the product that you wish find
on the shelves um we also have tenina
which is part of nestle you may well
know and um but we also have health
science and typically in The Institute
of Health Science that uh would be more
things around um you know
more nutrients so it's around intake
food intake but it's also regarding
different type of product that would be
delivered in the hospitals for instance
uh and that would then require different
approaches and clinical studies and
these kind of things
so it's already pretty diverse and that
would have been that is still I would
say a challenge to
have sessions where everyone is
interested in in the topic so
sufficiently I would say um sufficiently
uh you say that in English um sharp in
technically uh but sufficiently broad so
that we are not lost by the by the
science behind if it's not in our more
familiar domain so so yeah Mesley is a
massive company right like I'm I'm
assuming most people are familiar with
it but jean vinant do you wanted to sort
of maybe give folks a lay of the land of
like Nestle as an
entity well um so I as I've just said to
give a number it's around 300,000 people
around the world uh it's uh I don't know
how many hundreds or thousands of
factories uh and then um while it has
this particularity as I said that it's
um it's kind of so it's a Swiss base
Swiss originally from so the
headquarters are in vve in swiland by
Lake Geneva which she's called L Lio if
you whole de on the region um and uh
it's Swiss spirit in the sense that it's
decentralized even though there is the
center in V but there is always um a
will to
have products that are adapted to the
local market so there is a some sort of
autonomy that is also given to the
different market so what we call a
market is not necessarily a country but
if it's a big country it's just a
country but can be also a group of of
some of some countries uh and basically
well it's I think the first food and
beverage uh company and our main
products and are R coffee we are we are
producing a lot of of NES Cafe typically
it's one of the wellknown brand you also
of nepresso as I mention also Pina in
the in the pet food
um there is also all the chocolate
chocolate C I don't know if if how um
there is um how it's spread um but they
also very there are product that are
typical to certain regions typically I
think Milo is South
American so then there are many
sometimes many brands that I'm I'm even
still discovering that I didn't know
existed uh so so it's pretty bro so but
really supplying food beverage around
the world I would say yeah and your your
previous company valtronic is that is
that
the how how different is Nestle from
from that
company uh well you have different
aspects so first vonic is 500 people
around the world so it's smaller than
one Center in nesle say now in nle
research where are more than 700 located
in in loan around the loan area um and
so in that sense is uh is it was much
smaller so of course you can um have
also responsibility at a global
scale much quicker I would say
in a career there um but still it was
International in the sense that vonic
has to the headquarters in in in
Switzerland there is uh well there was
at the time a engineering Bureau in
Romania and then there was a factory in
Morocco still Factory in Morocco and a
factory in the US in Sol on Ohio um and
um so there is still also this diversity
because in the sense that so the Maron
company Plant was really to to produce
with
um less expensive um Workforce um so it
was more
decentralizing uh but the US company was
a lot more autonomous and serving more
the US market so there was also there
also this aspect of uh of
having this um serving the local needs I
would say from the company um then it's
different also in the well the activity
was is a little bit different because we
do not uh we do not develop electronic
devices in mesle whereas AIC was really
on electronic
devices um and uh yeah so I would say um
there is also maybe the the size of the
company really makes a big difference in
the sense
that
uh well there are two things first
uh there might be some more constraints
in valtronic because it's medical so
aside from the medical part of nesle but
and still nesle is a food company so
there is a lot of constraints for around
food safety for for instance obviously
uh but uh on the other hand um nle being
a really big company needs to have you
know all of these process that are
inherent to every big company I would
say and vonic was maybe a little bit
more
[Music]
on we can do different things um uh but
but yeah
it's still to to to a certain extent so
then I would
say it would be more directly closer to
a startup even though while I'm saying
this I'm also thinking that some part of
nesle are also shaped to be uh like I
would say startup like or have this
Freedom so there is still even though
there is this a big company result of
the process and everything uh which is
giving also a certain you know security
and coherence uh then there is also this
this Innovation and Entrepreneurship
that is feasible into some some areas of
the company yeah there is a an anonymous
question asking what is the difference
between your role as a head of
technology and now a data scientist I'm
doing more Hands-On things as a data
scientist that also one of the goal you
know when you are head of Technology
it's um uh the activity was a lot around
supervising uh people um not supervising
in terms of people management but more
in terms of uh technical outcome that
they were producing and there was also a
lot of activity around um interaction
with the the the customers or with the
the the prospects so I would then work
with the with the sales people uh and
then you know when they they would come
to me oh I have this new guy who would
like to do this and this do you think
it's feasible um I don't know if you if
you're familiar with the with the
the YouTube video where it says I'm an
expert I can do everything you know with
the seven perpendicular lines with blue
ink that are red um for those who doing
a belt and then you would see these are
the types of times of you know you're
the the head of Technology the the
expert coming in and and then firsthand
say whether it's possible or not so um
and in that regard I'm not doing this
anymore at all as a data scientist in N
because I I'm um uh I'm involved in the
project I would say really much more
Hands-On and I might then um there is no
um interaction with uh I would say
customer who would have a specific
project it would be more internal
customers and internal project that are
being shaped and and and developed so
um yeah so so uh there is this hands on
thing and I could really much more focus
on data science activity itself uh and
develop also in that field that is that
is also taking off a lot with now more
recently also um on on on AR uh data
sets as well very good thank you there
was a question uh posted by I think
Neils uh sorry if I mispronounced that
but Neils I'll give you a second if you
want to ask that yourself otherwise I
can ask it yeah sure can you hear me
loud and clear thanks
awesome uh yeah so my question was
around I think you mentioned something
about um collecting some some data files
from the lab using shiny so I was just
wondering if you could talk about the
process around identifying shiny as the
correct tool to do this and then whether
you had any interaction with the
stakeholder to get approval for using it
and then um as an add-on to that what
development challenges did you meet if
any when using shiny and
Enterprise thanks yeah okay so
um uh basically why using shiny it's
because we're using R to start with uh
so basically the data analysis that I've
been doing so we have an internal
package that is called
nesat I participated to in developing
some code around design of experiment
analysis uh and so just to say that we
have a rather intense
activity using r as as the software for
folding our analysis uh especially when
it comes to um you know sometimes from
the lab you you can have some more and
more automatic uh automatic uh or
semi-automatic um equipment that could
generate a lot of data like Auto
Samplers yeah like
robotic systems and things like this and
uh when you comes to that you have a lot
of different files
a lot of files which are not so
different they are the same structure
but it's a lot of them and you know copy
pasting it in Excel and trying to do
something out of that is kind of painful
and so very Qui when I come to this
situation uh I would then start coding
in order to do the loading automatic
data wrangling put things together have
a nice graph with nice colors using
ggplot and so on so I'm a tidy verse fan
by the
way and then um then then with with this
you have your
code and then you get your colleague
from the lab or from the project
management saying hey that's very nice
but now I have new files and I would
like to do it again and the same
analysis and the same display and then
and over and over and over so after some
time you say hey look I can just package
that into a nice web interface uh and
then uh then you can do it on your own
and then if there is anything do going
wrong then you can just let me know and
I will uh I will also uh I will also
then update it uh other things that
could happen typically to give you an
example why been doing this is um so
well you it's not a secret that a coffee
machine is is pushing water through a
system and then with water you have also
some pressure and then so you have some
curves of pressure against time or
temperature Against Time this kind of
thing and then we are interesting uh to
uh interested in what is you know the
maximum here what is the blood what is
the local minimum what is the local
thing and is the variability so all
these features extracted that are then
theyed into that and they would run
their own analysis on the features but
they need to extract these features and
a typical shiny app would be something
where they could upload the road data
and then get back a CSV file where they
have the features analyzed and
extracted so now how did we manage to
have this in the
company
um so I would say a key thing is to have
a good a good relationship with it
because they are the the Guardians of
the compliance for I it's really
important and and for very good reasons
especially in a company as exposed as as
big companies I would say any big
company um and uh well it it went so the
first thing that I mean at some point I
had also you can also have shiny apps
that you just like locally deploy in in
in in the computer Compu and then you
can also have your colleague having R
installed and then you can just we set
it by this sometimes by the way to have
a kind
of uh bash file to just start the
process and they would double click on
it and then it would open automatically
R and shiny behind and then they would
have the the page but then it's sitting
on their computer and if we want to
update anything then we need to to go to
the computer again uh so they was some
discussion also already from from the
center where people saying oh that would
be interesting and then you know
connecting with it you you managed to
put it into the sufficiently secured and
closed environment but still available
in the
internet uh and then more recently we
moved with Azure and then then it goes
into into Azure with Azure Solutions um
uh and and then that's also where you
can manage the access you can manage the
visibility of the the virtual machine so
now we just the Ser is about the virtual
machine and uh and yeah so the the thing
is to have our it counterparts that
are aligned with with us so basically
what we I was working enough I could
describe the needs that we had as as a
programmers and data scientists and then
they would uh they came back with some
proposal and then we moved together to
to have something is up and
running um
so uh I don't know if I covered the
whole question because you asked me
also uh yeah how how do we uh if there
any well hurdles in the big company yeah
we said it's just is um having the the
right the right people but it's also a
matter of um of uh of good compromise I
would say because of course you you are
not in the world as open source and or
you would not you know um typically our
code is versioned into a git system but
inside in house we would not put our
code on GitHub because it's a private
company uh so you need to to have this
this understanding and then uh you know
also explaining what are the needs that
we have typically in R&D we have some
needs that are um inherent to research
and development we cannot predict what
we will discover because it's research
and development I mean so and and
sometimes this is a bit you know
difficult to to handle when you speak
with people who are used to deploy an
app and the app is doing what it's
supposed to be doing and we know and we
know everything and there is no doubt
and that goes with it so there was also
this discussions around that to really
understand each other's needs and
perspective because you cannot either go
freely like say ah I'm R&D I'm creative
I want to do everything and and and
voila no no you need to play also by the
rules for the good reason and understand
them regarding your comment about good
relationships with it and Travis I see
you uh made a comment we do hear that a
lot I like to sort of ask like what are
some concrete steps or things that you
can do to actually build a good
relationship with it because sometimes
it can be a statement akin to like
deliver a great customer experience it's
like okay what does that actually mean
and look
like um I would say yeah the the good
relationship with it is
um I would say like any human
relationship it's understanding also the
the other's
perspective uh it's it's really um you
know most of the time really in the very
vast majority uh when someone is is
bothering us uh with some constraints is
not by Pleasure or just to make our life
worse it's because they they need to
deliver on something and they are also
accountable for something and then we
need to uh to make sure that that we
also speak the same same not same
language but at least we have the a
common ground of understanding so I
would say that would be one of the key
things I mean I remember like for
instance
um yeah there might be things that you
are not aware of uh typically on on some
of the data access or some of of the the
systems access you say yeah I would like
to have it open you know in the the way
of sharing sharing know sharing science
sharing everything uh and then they say
yeah but you see uh this and this can
happen and actually did already happen
and you didn't know that so listen to
the stories also that they have to tell
us uh where it comes from all these uh
these frame that was put in place and
and afterwards it's even better because
once once it's it's well set then you
can really work uh in in a confident
manner in in in a safe
environment so yeah I would say
understand listen to to the other but
also be able to explain your your
perspective and your needs uh in in a in
a in a most objective way I would say
bottom line is to to
say to say yeah I need to this is how I
I see and and I see someone is
commenting one gur relationship with it
do not lose patient yes absolutely I
think patience is also a good thing but
um but yes I'm not saying I'm succeeding
every time sometimes I've I'm I'm you
know passionate I would say but yes it's
I try to to understand also their
perspective there are I want to go to
the anonymous questions there's a few of
them um one is do you miss supervising
people do you still supervise people I
find that it seems like an inevitable
path to progress but I don't know if I'd
be any good
uh that's a good question because that's
exactly one of the reason I moved also
to
nle so I think it's
inevitable to do some sort of
supervision uh now the the great thing
as
[Music]
as have the chance to have in that we
have a path where we can develop
expertise and that's what I've chosen so
I'm not developing into managing more
and more people having a group than a
department than Institute or whatever uh
I'm I'm more developing the expertise in
data science but still with a certain
level of
seniority you people come to you and ask
you for help ask you for feedback ask
you for having some you know can you
have a look at what I've done and then
tell me and then also people would ask
you well from your perspective what
strategic decision would you recommend
so you know at some point you take this
also span when when when when you grow
in
in the career so um that's why I say
it's inevitable to to do some sort of
management so I would say I have I more
have um I don't have direct report as of
now uh but I have uh you know indirect
or dotted line type of of relationship
also I may supervise Sometimes some some
students or in in case like this but
it's it's more
um yeah something I would say
like coaching and
[Music]
consel type of activity um still with
the responsibility that goes with it
because I've got the experience
sometimes that I've got some feedback
where uh um yeah senior leader would ask
some project manager to who's presenting
the project so these are the conclusions
and then oh did you check it with and
then if they say yes then they say oh
okay that's fine so you're kind of the
the the the validation of the expertise
and it goes with the responsibility
because if it fails behind then that's
somehow also your credibility that is at
stake so but I would say that yeah
that's really something that that is
occurring I in career there was an
anonymous question I think it referred
to a previous conversation it's what is
a head of technology I guess the implied
question is like what what does that
entail but well that it's exactly in
this line of not having a typical um
direct
report
um at the time I was uh transversal into
the different uh groups uh and um so I
would be the go-to person if there was a
technological question uh in in the
company uh and then uh also trying to
coordinate across the different groups
the different different activities uh so
that would mean uh you know reviewing
what the different Engineers are doing
uh giving them also some uh some
feedback on on on the on on the results
they obtain and maybe also some guidance
on how they would do the next experiment
or how they would address the next uh
process challenge um and then uh yeah
also being the conselor for relationship
with outside so when someone is coming
and saying okay I would like to do this
new implant with that technology uh do
you think you can bring me a solution
with this and then uh with having
discuss result and having an overview of
all the project technology speaking in
the company then you can have a good uh
insight and say well we think we can do
that this in that way in that way or
with this and this challenges or in that
time frame and so on so that would be
also the type of activity there was a
question and sorry if I'm pronouncing
your name wrong from tankage um I don't
know if you want to join in I see her on
I see her on video if you want to join
in but I'm happy to ask it as well hi hi
hi U yeah John thanks for the insightful
things that you have been telling it's
really helpful one question was more
around uh shiny application that you're
using uh what kind of database or data
store or data warehouse would you
typically suggest uh as a back end for
shiny application and uh major L when
there is a huge scale we are talking
about like 100 200 GB data in the back
end well that's a question maybe for
some of the posi people online also that
would give you a a more complete
answer uh to be really transparent I I'm
not dealing with that big databases um
but from what I know that uh that that
we have been using uh uh there I would
say our chosen solution
is around azur so I would say a
cloud-based solution is is something
that that would that would be um I would
say the preferred solution because you
would not download 200 g gigabytes on
your on your laptop because that won't
work and you need to Al to scale up your
your computing power uh which is which
is I think something that is really a
big advantage of of cloud Solutions in
general they this flexibility of of
computing power um and then
uh yeah I'm not sure how much for shiny
apps you can handle that size of data
basis uh but definitely what you can do
also is have some backend pre-processing
because depending on what you want to
display I mean in the end you may not
want to display the the the the hundreds
of millions of points you want to
display some summary data some some
knowledge extracted from it so I would
uh I would then from what I know I mean
this I would maybe use things like like
you know data breaks or or or data
Factory in Azure I don't know about um
about Amazon and and Google clouds so
that's why I'm speaking about this one
so I'm not you know selling anything
it's just that I'm speaking what I've
experience and then you can prepare your
data and then your shiny app can then uh
um get the the relevant data that is uh
that is uh then useful for for this
plane
so and it depends also on your
application because why I'm saying this
maybe you want to recalculate some
things B on the full set depending on
what is the user what is the user input
but I would really um try to um to take
care of having as much as possible uh
pre-processing data with things that
where you can call very comp very
powerful
clusters uh I I don't know if if you
imagine situation where you have some
data and then maybe once a day or once
every 24 hours or twice a day you would
have you would turn on the very powerful
cluster that is a lot expensive prepare
data save it somewhere in a data lake or
in structured
database shiny works well with I've I've
done some shiny application with with
with cloud with with yeah a data leg so
it's really like a file system um but
you can also work with with SQL database
very very well that are in in the in the
cloud there is also some uh you can work
with with Cosmos DB that are bit more
flexible but then I would imagine
something like when you have your big
storage then your data bricks would in R
and python you can do both you can then
would query and then get your data
analyze save it in a way that is
prepared for the shiny app so that the
shiny app is a lot more reactive when it
has really the minimum data it needs to
to be efficient and to serve the the
need so it really depends on on what you
need because if you want to program or
to get to recompute everything every
time you have a query or or reactive
action that is done on your app then if
very likely crash
uh quite quickly so so I would yeah
prepare this in that way understood
thanks thanks a lot joh Ahad I see your
hand is raised yeah um I had a quick
question um so a little bit about my
background is beforehand I used to um
have no coding experience whatsoever I
had to learn as a means to an end and so
I just had a data Camp subscription and
was frantically searching on stack
Overflow before my deadlines and uh the
experience that I had was a little bit
stressful and to be quite Frank I was a
little intimidated um sort of uh
stepping into this newer space and more
technical space and so John V I'd love
to get your perspective on if you've had
any experience with coaching and helping
other people lower the barrier to entry
in terms of uh learning how to code
learning how to apply code coding
principles so their data science work
because the initial uh barrier can be a
little um a little daunting a little
scary at first at least in my experience
um so I just love to hear your
experience about playing that Mentor
role and if you have any tips and tricks
for us um yeah sure so um first I would
say uh the key thing is that the person
starting should be uh well I think if
you're interested into the into coding
then that's that's a very good first
setep people there is the barrier is
people some people are scared by the
code and and some are not so if you are
scared I would recommend you do
something else but if you are not then
it's a good it's a good thing and then I
would say um
yeah maybe two three tricks but maybe
they they're kind of abuse you can uh
have some example code typically you
never you rarely start from nowhere so
you always have more or less good
quality I mean I uh well so I I started
also coding in my life I didn't I was
not born coding so so sometimes some of
the other people would give me some some
some part of code that
was okay and then I could start reading
it and understanding it and then
adapting it so you can have a first
thing is that this is your example code
and then and then adapt it so maybe
having a colleague that can give you
also some things and then something that
is that is really um I would say helping
is to do not hesitate to have regular
sessions like weekly where you just
review the code and uh even if you have
a question then you can go yes T
overflow or yeah I'm not sure that that
chat GPD is doing a very good job I had
some hallucinations in there so double
check with the internet as well uh then
it can help and and then you can you can
but I mean I've stuck over FL the lot of
course um and then uh then it's going to
have it's good to have also this session
let's take an hour or two hours sometime
in the week we sit together explain me
your code that's where are the different
intentions comment your code I would say
also don't hesitate to put comments even
for yourself this is what I'm doing here
this is what I'm doing here and this is
you know just a few a few notes uh and
um and then with someone more experience
can then uh propose some some
alternative way of doing the analysis or
alternative way of a more efficient way
and
um yeah so so in terms of of coaching is
there is this
um because yeah sometimes it happened to
me that you
know I get uh I get um to review a code
with someone and then U you say yeah but
you can do it a lot more efficient this
way so it's not only a matter of being
you know competition efficient sometimes
yes because it takes several minutes or
hours to compute so you you better have
something more efficient that is is
really
dramatically
reducing but sometimes also it helps
also the code to be clearer and then if
you have Elegant uh coding then in the
end you also have a better understanding
of what is happening and and you you
keep track and you you avoid hidden
mistakes because in the code you can
have cases where
um uh the the code doesn't work and it
gives you an error that's kind of easy
you have a capital letter somewhere that
was not there you don't have the right
package okay that's kind of quickly
fixed but I would say the most
problematic error is when it does
everything and then it outputs something
that is not supposed to output and if
you cannot spot that that's that's
pretty complicated so what that's when
you have a clear code and and an elegant
code you can you can more easily follow
I would say what is going on uh and
typically yeah that's where things
like what we have in yeah in terse again
or with the pipe and these kind of
things and we can have something that is
a lot uh uh easier to to follow and um
and sometimes what can be good also is
to set some
challenges uh and I set myself at some
point I said now from now on my code in
R will have zero for loop I did
everything without for Loop first it's
more efficient and sometimes it helps
you so think a bit
differently but with apply typically
with everything around the
apply map map to the map whatever you
have map dfr map
the then you can do a lot of things and
um and then you have this um this
also way to to have to have something
that is working and I would say um it
also helps developing the functions
aspect so it's also good to say okay I
can have a function doing this a
function doing this and you build your
your code like this way also in the
clarity part this function is taking my
data from this to this and then I have
the next to
this
TR I say Jeff is not do not agree with
me it's not more efficient to use yeah
okay clear there is this parallelization
that you can use um but well I had some
examples um that actually was uh was uh
where have more efficiency we can we can
this in a specific thing I think that
could be there is one thing that is a
lot a lot
efficient is however don't forget that R
is using uh is
um I mean use Matrix calculation so
typically the worst thing to do is to
scan through a data frame uh because and
always think that you can use the object
and and uh and manipulate them as such
Ravis I see you as to question and I'm
very curious where are you dialing in
from San Diego back back uh home I guess
these days um I don't I admittedly don't
know a lot about food science um but I'm
so I'm in the Pharma side and the notion
of whether or not you have to submit
data products or um kind of reports to
the FDA or other Regulatory Agencies um
do you have to do so there's a lot of
conversation in the farma biotech World
about how to do these things with r um
it's often met with some resistance just
because they're more used to seeing sass
um wonder if that's a thing you've had
to come
across well I haven't personally come
across this um I know some people while
SAS is also a software we use in this
not personally using it but it has been
used um I'm not in that part of the the
process so fortunately I cannot give you
any details on this but there are um
there are clearly a lot of activities
around around that anyway because we
have food safety
specialist and we have even an Institute
that is dedicated to food safety uh so
so this is really something uh that's
there but and probably they've been
doing some Mission also to FDA
especially if we speak about health
science uh
development but beyond this I'm I'm
afraid I don't have any any experience
in that in that regard for for this yeah
no worries thanks no it' be interesting
um you know as as a follow-up sometime
you know the the conversation I think is
often dominated by the Pharma and
biotech World um but I imagine you all
struggle through the same sorts of
things um on the food science and health
science side interested if we all chat
together you know yeah okay yeah sure
let's burn through a few anonimous
questions um how much Freedom do you
have regarding the tools that you
use um as much as I can justify the need
I would say in the
sentence um
it's true we cannot use anything we want
we need to use approved uh tools um but
as far as I'm concerned from my
day-to-day work I have a lot of them so
I have a lot of tools and I have I would
say more than if enough
uh tools to
use sometimes I come across things I
would like to
implement uh and then yeah the process
is um
we we can come with a proposal but then
we we first need to come with with a
requirement we we need we need to do
this and this and this and these tool
answers my needs because of this and
this and this and then U it would come
back and tell me well maybe you can use
this uh which we already have in house
that I was and sometimes it happened I
was not aware of something and then I I
I have a new tool I can I can use um
that is actually answering the need
and if really there is uh there is a
good reason for uh for having a new tool
then then that's still okay I mean it
can be approved and uh and then then we
can move on with with it can I double
click and ask what what is the um if you
can share the process for a new tool
right so you discover something it's
amazing you you want to use it how do
you go about you know bringing that into
the workplace or what advice might you
give to
others well again as uh coming back to
it security I would really um come to um
first talk to to it uh representative to
say
um I wouldn't come saying I have this
new tool that is great please buy it
because that don't
work I would come say hey you know I've
come across this challenge in my uh in
my work and do you know anything about
that could help me with this particular
uh challenge I have that by the way is
entered by the two life found
out and then in the conversation you can
maybe suggest it and see whether they
know about it or not so because it's a
lot more you know okay saying and you
can say I may have a potential solution
but this is really what I need to have
uh at first to be to be
um to be answered in terms of of need uh
and then you can you can propose the
tool I think what's um how do you
navigate the the line or sort of
adopting open source tools right A lot
of the times they're they're free so you
can just sort of You Know download them
maybe there's not a purchase necessary
how do you go about or how do you
navigate not over involving it but
keeping them in the
loop um well first some of these free uh
tools they are
already many of them are have been
approv because you know it is kind of
also is doing the their job in terms of
scouting and being
aware of what is is going on typically
with we have the example with chat GPT
and you know what happened with with
Samsung uh so very early we had also
some communication internally saying uh
we know there is this coming out please
be careful about this and this
um so technically we are not uh if it's
an open source and free
tool that doesn't require admin rights
to install on new machine
you can do it but then you're
responsible for it I think this Freedom
also always comes with responsibility uh
so um I think it's okay and if you if
you address it this way also
with with with it who who is also
responsible for the for the overall
security of the of the company uh then
um then it goes in the right direction
because you
say look I would like to use that uh
it's always good to have a double check
can maybe uh ask the question you can
test it on your own personal computer at
home say I I've done some test at home
and it look good because of this and
this what do you think applying it into
the into this uh and if you have this
reflection so you may not need to for
each and every step go to to them but um
if you have behind also uh the
reflection also okay what would be you
know kind of doing a sort of light risk
assessment
Also regarding the company and taking
into consideration the company's need
and
perspective then after some time you get
used to it and say okay maybe this I'm
pretty confident I can do some test and
and have some reflection and then you
can just double check um and some other
things you would ask from St because you
know it might not be so straightforward
and yeah just make sure that um that you
have also this kind of you know rational
and reflection on on this
very good there is a I want to make sure
we get to all of the anonymous questions
so we're coming to the top of the hour
so if you have any uh burning questions
submit them on slat or put them in in
the chat but uh one that we didn't get
to so far is what are your aspirations
for the future in your role in your role
or longer term well that's um it's an HR
question uh no it's really I think I'm
really interested into this whole field
of um
uh well basically trying to get
knowledge you know extract the knowledge
and understanding of the phenomenon uh
from from the from the data and we have
more and more data so I would say uh
really growing in in in in this and
being also aware of what is what is U
what is is emerging I mean recently we
have if you look a bit in in the history
we have been having some some statistics
and then doing some linear regression or
then he came to random for now we have
Transformer architecture that can be
applied Beyond
text in some cases so uh you know
getting more of these things and and
trying to to connect dos between the
different things that uh that are
valuable or that emerge also from from
the academic research um yeah to I would
say continue in in that field so then by
doing this it it's uh in terms of
personal you know
uh
development um typically in the expert
in the expert expertise aspect you can
then start to also give lectures in in
some universities or in some schools and
then to see uh to also share the your
your knowledge here and get the feedback
also from from from different uh from
the students and from different people
so I I would say that would be a Natural
Evolution you know it's also to to go to
reach beyond the company uh for for this
and which is by way aligned with with
the company
also company policy very good so I think
that wraps up the uh anonymous questions
and I I don't see any outstanding ones
in the chat obviously feel free to raise
your hands everyone um I like to
typically end or ask like not to put you
on the spot but I guess to put you on
the spot what advice do you have uh for
data scientists or aspiring data science
leaders leaders in uh in particular
um yeah well you have many different uh
angles here but if I had to pick one um
uh I would say um it's evolving very
very very fast so I think uh being
curious on new things and always trying
to well with moderation of course
because you need also to deliver and to
be to be efficient so I would say uh
yeah being curious on what what is
coming up and and and the new
discoveries and
then don't hesitate to to to test these
new things on to see if it performs
better than the current techniques that
you would have so far um but then also
um keep the as a leader keep the right
balance between having new things and
still also letting the time for the
people that you are maybe leading uh to
to learn about them and and to still
deliver in what they have to do in the
everyday life because you know sometimes
uh you have to you have these new things
that you want to try but still the
projects are moving on and and good
statistics or more classical approaches
also deliver well so there is a good
balance to find between between the how
to deliv with what you know already but
still having this curiosity and and
openness to to try new things that may
also open some new
opportunities are there any particular
Avenues or channels that um you use an
occupy to stay up to date and and learn
new trends well uh I would say I get
some some news uh some news that are
coming uh from you know
um what did
I I'm not registered to a specific
Journal I would say it's more you know
scattering like this um sometimes also
it there is no one channel I would say
really it's really
as you as the question I realize this
because you know sometimes I get
something on LinkedIn and I'm like oh
that's interesting and I pull the thread
and then see what what what's there Al
some most the time we have a specific
challenge to solve in a project and then
there is a company or there that we can
work with then that would be the spread
I would pull you know to to better to
better understand it so I would it's
really more opportunistic and systematic
way I would say but maybe that maybe I
could change it that could be a good but
so frightful that
way very good well we are at the top of
the hour so Jean Von thank you so much
for your participation and and
Leadership today if folks want to ask
you uh more questions or get in contact
with you um what's the best way to to uh
connect with you well I would say Linkin
LinkedIn uh but uh don't uh I mean just
um be careful to um send a small not not
that it was during the posit talk posit
hangout because you know I tend to uh to
to not accept
LinkedIn contacts if I don't know the
person I haven't met you know it's kind
of a rule I've set for myself because
you know otherwise you get a so don't
hesitate to connect but leave a leave
leave a word and and then then we can
most probably I would come back to you
saying yeah let's have a chat and then
and then we
connect
it's a good
rule that's right but include a note uh
very good it was nice seeing everyone um
next week it'll be regularly scheduled
program with with Rachel but uh Jean
Manon thank you so much I hope everyone
has a great rest of the day and week
thanks so much thank you for me thank
you everyone for your questions talk to
you soon see you all see you
byebye